[Music]
my name is
madison i had a one-night stand with
cody you know we were more friends
we had hung out a few times but she was
definitely hesitant about
going anywhere further than friends
how'd it all happen how did it start
one night she invited me over for some
drinks did you guys drink
i honestly can't remember at all uh we
were drinking
vodka i remember we had gone to her room
and then i think i had kissed her a
little bit and we were laying on the bed
like the actual initiation of sex was
kind of weird
and i think that she got a little upset
and she said that she didn't want to
have sex and she just wanted to hang out
i
had talked about not being sure that i
wanted to continue
and him really wanting to and i don't
know i was so
on the fence about it i understood the
way she felt and
i didn't want to push anything if she
didn't want to do it and then what
happened
a little later i may have initiated
kissing
she seemed into it everything was good
and then you said
i want to have
so yeah so i definitely said that i was
going to have so i'm like
okay all right well okay this is so
weird isn't it
that's what i was talking about earlier
there's something that we've
why am i hearing this okay one two
things
this kind of scenario is very common for
a lot of people
one and two hearing it orally
always sounds way more awkward and weird
than when you're going through the
motions themselves i i said that i
wanted to
i just was having a lot of nervousness
it was just kind of a weird mix of
emotions all at once and
i didn't really have a good idea of how
to be a good communicator when it came
to like
sexual desires that's a huge problem
what she just described right there i
think is like one of the biggest
issues it kind of reminds me of the aziz
ansari thing
where they were kind of getting it on
but things weren't communicated but
no more thing nothing was clearly verbal
but things were kind of like
implied right so and you hear just with
the way they're telling their story both
of them remember differently she's like
i don't remember drinking he's like we
definitely drank we had some vodka she's
like oh we watched a movie he's like
yeah we just slid into bed and we
started making out
so the memories and the way you remember
the signals are completely
different is really different that's a
known fact how you remember things are
probably not how it happened
no well you know eyewitness testimony
for most court cases are
notoriously unreliable because the way
people remember things is always altered
sometimes it's altered by what you read
in the news
like people's memory is so
even though it can viscerally make you
feel something when you try to think
back on it you add details
i was having this conversation with my
brother we used to live in the same
house for most our lives
and then i ended up living in ethiopia
for some time so i had to move back to
africa
and i remember before living
in ethiopia we lived in this tiny
apartment when i came back from ethiopia
i ended up living in a new house so i
was telling this to my brother right
like man do you remember when we
before i left we lived in that piece of
[ __ ] apartments like bro
you lived in that apartment when you
came back for like almost a year
and i was like what he's like you don't
remember this and i was like
[ __ ] my memory is garbage
but he was right that's how it did
happen but you can misremember things
that you think are so clear
my mom don't even remember i was i got
left back he said you never got left
back
yes left oh you repeated a year yeah i'm
like yes i'm in school
yes fourth grade they put me back no you
never did
what the what are we doing here look at
my sister and she's like
what's going on that's crazy right
here's what's even more [ __ ] up this
is how
two people can have an experience and
remember it completely different and
none of them actually think they did
anything wrong
right because two people can think this
happened five years ago
and i think the reason why i was
bringing up like both people can
remember things like
sometimes when people remember things
differently like yo she's lying
or he lied about this like or maybe you
guys just
remember this completely differently
your mom wasn't lying
when she said you didn't go backwards in
her head that's realist
no it's just it's just the fact that she
wouldn't accept that
but now here's something even more what
if you had repeated third grade
but you remembered as fourth grade now
both of you are convinced the other
person's lying when both of you are just
wrong about what happened
i know it's fourth grade i remember my
teacher's name like come on now
i'll just give you an example but yeah
that's the thing about memory it's
faulty
what do you remember her body looking
like oh sh she has definitely has an
amazing body
i was really insecure
that's me with most ladies but that's a
perception yeah that's a perception
even if the girl is hot she's going to
have insecurities even if the guy is hot
she's going to have a certainty people
are going to have insecurities people
are going to be
viewed not how they view themselves so i
know but it's just funny it's just like
that experience of me looking at it girl
be like god damn gorgeous
and the girl sitting there with like her
panties and her bra and she's like body
languages like this
did uh you use protection uh we used
protection i do remember that i feel
like it was something
weird like a cherry flavored condom or
something like that
i don't think that we use protection god
damn
whoa that's memory though this
that's memory memory can be completely
different this is hard to watch
but but keep on bro i had a sexual
experience with one girl one time
because she was like telling me like
remember that first time we did was
really good i was like
do you realize i was passed out and i
woke up inside you
and she's like no that's not what i was
like yeah that's how it happened i
remember
i remember waking up and be like oh this
is happening
but she doesn't remember that and so
that's what i'm telling you people can
remember these things
so she just went on what do you mean she
she did her thing while you were passing
out
i remember waking up like god damn this
is amazing
moving on how long did it last it had
lasted
quite a while 10 minutes
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna come to his
defense in two ways one
ten minutes can be long time for some
people no no listen
ten minutes can't be ten minutes if i
had average every once
in a while the thing is i believe that
10 minutes for a guy is longer than for
a girl
it's a it's longer for 10 minutes is
longer for a girl
if she's on top and our knees starts to
you know
when she's doing all the work now the
ten minutes gotta feel long
but for a guy that's doing all of that
work is
it's it's long it's it's you know women
do that whole like squatting thing like
that third wheel squat
they don't and they last like 30 seconds
and they're like okay support me and i
was like [ __ ] why'd you even get in
this that 10 minutes
you spent longer getting in this
position than you were in the position
which is like it depends
who's doing what i do distinctly
remember this part
about halfway through into this i just
started to have this
anxiety and panic and kind of weirdness
and in the middle of sex when i get that
way mentally
i start to disassociate and i don't know
that it was
all that enjoyable for either of us i
actually don't remember a lot of
when we were having sex i remember that
it was good
anxiety on people doesn't always show
and especially if you're not sensitive
to and you're not used to being around
the other person you may not know what
anxiety looks like on them
yeah that exactly looks like difference
with other people so some people here
can be like man i can't believe he
wasn't more thoughtful in that moment
and
also being that moment not realize that
the other person is going through
something
i've had nervous breakdowns in front of
people and they had no idea
i was having panic attacks in front of
people like like
like everything in my skin was crawling
like 70 million
never like for me that's how my panic
attacks used to happen i used to be in
front of like
at the bus stop and just feel like
hundreds of of bugs were under my skin
and i couldn't like
it was crazy nobody could tell around so
that's the thing that people have to
realize is sometimes you may not be able
to see people suffering
what was the aftermath so you get up in
the morning the next morning
everything seemed fine but she didn't
want to hang out again and i said well
why don't you want to hang out
i texted him and i was mad at him for
what it felt like in the moment that he
had pressured me into having sex
and i said well you never i mean you
said that earlier and then i understand
and then we started kissing in bed and
then we had sex
and so there was never any cody i don't
want to do this
later in the night so i was definitely a
little upset i just told him that he was
a
dick for not taking into account that i
wasn't sure that i wanted to have sex
and i didn't want to see him again and
so i just cut ties and i never
saw him again did sleeping with her ruin
your guys's relationship
yeah if you could go back would you have
done things differently
yeah i think i would have taken things
slower and uh
and just tried to feel out the way she
really felt instead of trying to rush in
and have sex that night
cody describes leading up to you guys
having for the first time that you guys
were friends that would hang out
that's that's how i saw it how did you
what did you think it was
i thought we were like seeing each other
oh me okay you know what this
is this is probably i think the greatest
problem
facing dating today is that people
don't know how to communicate what they
want
that's it sometimes people are not sure
of what they want but the other thing is
that they don't know how to communicate
it
and they just assume that the person is
going to understand it and so all these
misconceptions happen and you start to
read intent into other person not
understanding your perspective it's
super unfortunate it's tough because
dating
operates on a lot of like non-verbals
and an innuendo but
there's certain things that you guys
have to learn how to communicate
intentions
ideally um and at least if things are
stated
then if things don't pan out you can
read intent into that
but if you never ask those questions and
you just assume
and you don't get the outcome that you
want you can look at the person like oh
you're a demon when reality
they were just operating on a different
reality if you say hey i'd like to come
into your bank and i want to see what
accounts you guys have
you go in then you leave you're like
okay now i better be part of the
investment
team you're like what where did that
happen you just came in for a visit you
got to communicate these things
oh i definitely didn't see you as my
friend like
i don't have sleepovers with my male
friends okay the night of
sleeping with each other how did that
happen she had
asked me to come over we had a few
drinks and from what i remember
we had gone into the room and then
i think that i started kissing her and
she got upset and so
we left the room and went back in and
that's what
that's when we had that's kind of what i
remember okay
and we used a condom right i don't think
so oh [ __ ] we didn't
no because you didn't want to that's one
of the reasons
that's where the arguing came from holy
sh
that's so weird it all just hit me what
do you remember me telling you after
i remember you said that you weren't
ready
yeah like to have sex but at the time i
didn't get that
when you were initiating with me there
was a lot of like
pullback that i wasn't 100 sure i wanted
to do it and you were definitely like
into it and you're really pushing to
have sex and i was like you know what i
really like this guy
so i had with you and i can start to
like disassociate
during sex and that definitely
happened when we were together and being
disassociative in that kind of
action i guess or the environment of
what was happening is such a weird
kind of messed up feeling and i think i
just took
all of that and associated like those
negative feelings with you
because i just didn't know how to
process them you know
it totally makes sense when you actually
explain the whole thing to me this is
just
more indication of the fact that people
don't communicate well and
miscommunication is leading to what i
think is most of these problems
you know she essentially sacrificed her
comfort
because she liked him but then realized
that the price that she
paid wasn't worth it
and that's unfortunate and it's bad and
you
there's no easy answer to this stuff
guys there's no one-fix solution there's
no way that he can read
a lot of her signs it's hard
it's not easy and also she couldn't
she couldn't read his signs either she
couldn't tell that he saw her only as a
friend
you know both of them are incapable of
seeing where the other person is coming
from very clearly
and at least to these kind of situations
this is unfortunate but this is again
why people have to be more comfortable
communicating
man i still meet so many girls who tell
me like i just want a guy to kiss me
i want to just go for it that's not what
you mean
that's not what you mean i'm not talking
to you i'm talking to her listen i don't
think you should verbalize everything
but
we have to find a middle ground because
it's very clear that for a lot of people
they're not doing enough of it
as a result they're suffering that's an
issue yeah i'll just tell people
air on the side of caution that's the
best thing i could tell you guys if
someone is feeling kind of ambiguous
just air on the side of caution be like
well we're not going to proceed
and i know it sucks because nothing
really bad happened but
i think in this day and age better safe
than sorry
that's what i would tell people but yeah
leave your comments below we wanna hear
your thoughts
[Music]